Important because it studies those big
questions I mentioned,
especially the big question of how
should I live.
Nobody can be indifferent to that.
Everybody needs to have an answer to
that.
But most people don't think about it
very much.
Most people live and think at the level
of a Dva or if they're really
thoughtful,
they move it up to magazines or
occasionally they'll read a book.
But behind all of those things,
above all those layers are the great
books,
the sources of the thoughts that are
developed,
elaborated and the trickle down to
yes.
That uh,
we wouldn't pay enough attention to the
daily necessities of life or the moral
virtues of,
uh,
living with others who aren't a
philosophers or political philosophers.
Yes.
I think,
uh,
that would be a narrowing and you might
even forget a thing or two by being so,
I'm so isolated or,
or,
or so high above
most peoples,
we need to keep it
true to the great books,
to our tradition.
Our tradition is our substance.
Our tradition is a tradition of
questioning.
So it's not a stultifying tradition.
It's a tradition that keeps us aware.
Rake the lie.